foreign
ly I've had to lock this entry for the
following reasons
we originally found this entry on a
vinyl disk in the ruins of Saito 1.
when we inserted a copy of it into the
old Foundation database it was
automatically erased
we'd like to avoid anything like that if
possible
given the attention
scp-wiki.net has received recently we've
locked all of the pages in order to
prevent vandalism
please contact the foundation
preservation Guild for more information
[Music]
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is SCP 5800
object class ketter
special containment procedures
scientific institutions and
observatories must be prevented from
discovering
scp-5801 leaked and disseminated
information on scp-5801 must be taken
down and kept away from public knowledge
or addressed as a hoax Foundation
protocols must be kept in place to
prevent any entity or entities from
breaching this aperture
Foundation metaphysicians have prepared
an aim absolute idealistic materials
chamber around
scp-5801 to permanently seal away entity
or entities emerging from the aperture
description
scp-5800 is a hypothetical alternate
reality that is known in relativistic
physics as The Fifth Dimension specifics
of scp-5800 are unclear due to the
inability of Foundation Technology to
properly analyze mathematical and
anomalous dimensional constructs higher
than our own
scp-5800 retains radically different
ideals than the laws of physics of
Baseline reality
scp-5800 is host to living inconceivable
abstract Concepts that operate in the
noospheric Subspace similar to that of
biotic components interacting with one
another in a natural ecosystem most of
these abstract Concepts or entities are
predatory in nature and aggressively
envelop or dominate uighur ideatic
Concepts in order to increase in fractal
topology
scp-5801 is in aperture located
approximately 5.5 astronomical units
away from Earth and appears as a uniform
5 polytope schleafly symbol
t13334 with the Schlafly symbol
increasing in notation every 215 years
this aperture does not conform to
normative space-time and instead appears
to possess a tessellated geometry that
steadily increases in complexity to the
point that Foundation supercomputers are
incapable of processing a digital
representation of SCP 5801
scp-5800 was officially designated
following several events involving
scp-1425
scp-2155
scp-3005 and
scp-4565 and their effects on human
society following a more accurate
quantification of scp-5800 foundation
resources are to be devoted to its
neutralization
addendum 5800 one the petroslav notes
Igor petroslop
1689-1751 was a Russian Sorcerer And one
of the first to codify their practices
into what is now known as thamaturgy
towards the end of his life petruslove
discovered scp-5800 and began to perform
experiments on it following his death
petroslav's next of kin hid his work on
it in a hidden chamber in his stronghold
by petroslav's will this research was
not rediscovered until it was excavated
in 1996.
the following are relevant translated
paragraphs if there is a world of ideas
then there is a world that contains the
opposite of ideas
it took some experimentation to be able
to breach the boundary between these two
worlds but now I can see why it was
sealed that way
I found it to be frayed at the ends yet
overflowing with some substance that can
only accurately be described as light in
our universe
this light is very pleasing to take in
unfortunately it melts the mind and
causes Madness Abram stared into the
portal for the entire day and at the end
he couldn't say a coherent sentence that
didn't involve the color pink or the
side of smoke
in addition the light seems to have an
adverse effect on animals as my two cats
ran for their lives at the site of the
Albany
if my observations are correct I believe
that submerging anything inside of this
world will inevitably result in the idea
of remaining there Victor put an apple
inside of the portal before taking it
out the Apple slowly shifted forms in
color until it turned itself into a
green snake who spoke cautionary tales
about liquid hands and hateful stars in
the sky
I took the liberty of sealing the
aperture after that I'd rather not have
ideas interact with that world for a
prolonged period of time
addendum
5802 further research
the following is an audio recording of
Dr McLaurin one of the lead researchers
analyzing scp-5800's effects on human
cognition
all right I'm supposed to leave the
office but I can't be [__] to ride
anymore I've been bleeding out my nose
and ears for the past two days and it
keeps messing up my papers
right so what we've learned so far about
scp-5800 is that it's an ecological idea
space for extremely volatile abstract
concept these things have a hierarchy of
sorts which is dictated by the size of
these beings
I use the term size Loosely because the
there are these things are presented in
sets of Infinities like how many
integers or natural numbers there are in
in mathematics the sheer size of these
these beings are defined as uncountable
Infinities despite logic telling us that
there can't be anything larger in scale
than well Infinity
yes I know to the average Layman that
can't be possible but it is very much
true
these beings are represented by their
aleph numbers numbers which represent
the cardinality of infinite sets
Professor Hutchinson stated that such
beings exist in these numbers and have
been known to for quite some time
what we found out is that there is a
philosophy stemming around the hidden
potential of the human mind in order to
ascend past the boundaries of everything
one must secede from their personal
principles and unlock what's Within
these uh
it's just a metaphorical analogy and all
that ideas presented in a way for us to
understand how to be truly one with the
very handy that exists above us and sits
at a many angled Throne of stars and
pure radiance
a blissful
sorry uh I've got a bit carried away
there anyway there are sects that have
had a long history with her certain Keys
stretching all the way back to the Third
Crusade a key that could open all the
doors to the world and the mind itself
we haven't figured much about this door
though
I'm sure we have some keys locked up
that can open some doors or all those
but I don't know anything about a door
as far as I'm concerned I don't think
we've ever had a dog contained in the
first place
or did we
I don't
expect anyone to understand
Calvin and I have been working our asses
off on this thing and I I think it's
affecting us somehow they're telling us
to go on medical leave our research and
data on scp-5800 is getting pushed to
someone named Harkness is got more
experience with this than I do anyway
ah [__] out I'm getting light-headed as
hell right that about wraps up what's
been happening as of late
talk soon
addendum
scp-5801 exploration attempt
project border blue
after the appearance of SCP following
testing between SCP and SCP it was
determined that an exploration of the
anomaly would give greater insight into
its Origins a uralena class colony was
erected near the entrance of SCP
director Simon Browning was originally
selected to head exploration efforts
however l55 overrided protocol Alpha
contaminant in order to oversee
exploration themselves citing a need to
be precise
the colony was considered
self-sustaining on 2095 0329 a robotic
drone was to be deployed into the
anomaly on
2095-0409 however five days prior to
deployment site 19 command received the
following transmission
this is Agent straussen aboard your
Elena class Colony 1093 where undergoing
a situation can anyone hear us
this is Dr Johansson at site 19 in new
San Francisco Saturn what's the
situation we're being pulled into oscp
we believe that the mission is over
are you sure you're mentally well agent
from our telescopes it looks like the
colony isn't being pulled at all no I
don't know there's a light
there's a light and we're being pulled
into it
do you require us to send an evacuation
team
we're drifting away
and then no I don't think
I don't think they'd fare
an evacuation team was mobilized at site
19. however before evacuation could
occur The Colony suddenly vanished from
reality the only known survivors were oh
five five and several of his associates
who had escaped from the colony in a
custom Escape pod given the observations
of the colony and this incident SCP has
now been classified as a sub-anomaly of
scp-5800
notice the file below was found on the
same vinyl that we found the scp-5800
file on
given the fall of the foundation
occurred shortly after the events
described above this is believed to be
relevant
extended description of scp-5800
scp-5800-a refers to the concept of the
foundation as an entity after an event
on 2095 0505
scp-5800-a has been partially submerged
inside of scp-5800 this has had an
impact on Baseline reality causing the
alteration of the foundation's core
mission statement
the replacement of several high-ranking
officers with members of group of
Interest 5 the fifth Church
the release of many SCP artifacts and
entities due to new protocols
the absorption of several minor groups
of Interest such as group of Interest 49
the global occult coalition
incident log 5800 Trinity
on 2095 0505 the director of mobile task
force alpha 1 red right hand entered the
o5 council's main chamber as part of a
surprise inspection however they found
o55 performing a ritual involving the
sacrifice of several important
foundation personnel and the drawing of
a star in the floor using chalk while
will task force alpha 1 managed to
interrupt this ritual but suffered major
casualties
several modifications to the foundation
as a concept took place after the ritual
see extended description of scp-5800
above in response parts parts of the
foundation broke off with the goal of
overthrowing the L5 Council
interview log interviewer Dr Sean Remus
interviewee 055
begin log
have you heard of the chaos Insurgency
overseer of course I am doctor
the overseas have become tyrants
the Insurgency was formed because they
did not want to see the world ruled by
people with power left unchecked I think
we're trying to imitate them that's not
what this is really about is it no no no
the Insurgency turned out to be a
mistake in the long run
it's just a lot easier to Rally behind
the idea of eliminating tyrants than
eliminating ideas
that seems a little extreme to you
doesn't it so what's your story then
why have you suddenly changed the
foundation's prime directive and
absorbed the competition
you don't really get it do you do you
think we can just solve The World's
Problems by putting them all in boxes or
started boxes filled with the vilest and
darkest of evils
if this is about the number five there's
no scientific evidence that it is what
you claim it is but God God will cleanse
his Credit World this forsaken the
universe is a sin and we will be born
Anew in God's glorious dazzling light
it's not a fantasy shot it's not even a
reality
it is so so so much more than that and
Beyond
it's an Escape and we have the key to
bring it here okay
are you talking about scp-5800 when you
cut off the arm of a starfish what
happens what I don't
grows back right you have to know God's
omnipresence expands above all worlds in
every Universe we thought we could keep
it out by obliterating the very idea of
God's existence and it didn't even work
we tried to excise it from the very
Abyss in our heads we tried so damn hard
to cut it out but like a starfish it
grew back
you can't stop it God is here to bring
us what we deserve
with all due respect overseer you're
insane
what you thought you could just lock the
door and throw away the key it was
always there we put God on the other
side of the door and pretended that
everything was all right even though it
wasn't it never was but we can still try
to bring it here Remus deep down in the
moist music and the the orgasmic smoke
of your heart's mind you know it's true
we already have the key and we know what
the door is
all you have to do is let them in doctor
call your men off tell them to let them
in okay I think we've had enough here
Clifford do you think you can edit it
sir and lock
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
James Samba
braided Peach
fire of prime
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you